la suite de l'actualité avec d'abord
monsieur Badinter le ministre de la
Justice qui réunissait ce matin les
membres de la commission qu' l' nommé
pour réfléchir sur l'utilité ou non de
retransmettre le procès de Klaus Barb à
la télévision Dominique thierce a
rencontré Monsieur badind
historiquement nous n'avons pas les
éléments que nous aurions pu conserver
quel dommage que l'on nit pas la voix de
Léon Bloom au procès Pétin quel dommage
qu'on entende pas l'aval au début de son
procès se défendant lui-même quel
dommage qu'on n pas conservé
l'enregistrement du colonel argou au
moment du procès des barricades enfin
les archives judiciaires sont vides
parce que l'on ne sait pas assez soucié
de voir comment l'on pouvit réussir à
conserver des documents sonores ou
visuels suffisants ça n'est pas une
commission destinée à préparer une
décision concernant le procès Barb ce
serait inadmissible qu'on se m à
légiférer ou à prendre des décisions
réglementaires à propos procès en
particulier c'est un problème beaucoup
plus vaste et laaffaire Barbie c'est une
affaire parmi d'autres s'il y a une
modification de la loi elle vaudra pour
le procès Barb mais elle vaudra aussi
bien pour toutes les autres affaires
vous voyez c'est un problème général
mais ce que je tiens à marquer parce que
pour moi c'est
l'essentiel par-dessus tout il faut que
la justice soit
il ne faut pas que au nom des exigences
de la
communication la justice puisse être
troublé dans sa démarche le moins du
monde c'est la première exigence pour
une justice comme la nôtre et croyez-moi
j'y veill